und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und claus kleber guten
abend der cdu parteitag ist vorbei wenn
vorher streit in der luft lag dann ist
der gründlich abgeräumt wurden
vorübergehend wenigstens die stärkste
rede der ganzen veranstaltung kamen
heute erst gegen ende vom gast aus
bayern
es hat schon den söder markus gebraucht
um der schwesterpartei zu zeigen die
wahlkampfrede geht dass er das kann bei
eklat
und dazu kommt noch dass es einfacher
ist mit breiter brust aufzutreten wenn
einer die erfolge nicht nur für
unbestimmte zukunft verspricht sondern
auch schon welche hinter sich hat seine
lebensziele hat söder ja schon erreicht
wie er sagt bis auf weiteres jedenfalls
andreas weise über den abschluss hin er
ist der stargast am letzten tag des cdu
parteitages in leipzig bayerns
ministerpräsident und csu chef markus
söder glichen frühere besuche von
csu-vorsitzenden er krisengipfeln so ist
heute die botschaft wir haben uns alle
lieb eine große ladung unions
selbstbewusstsein aus münchen
wer vier wahlen hintereinander gewinnt
er kann es nicht so schlecht gemacht
haben und darum lasst uns immer neues
denken aber stolz darauf sein was wir in
den letzten jahren für deutschland
gemeinschaft mit geleistet haben
der politische feind für söder vor allem
die fdp afd ist nicht irgendwie eine
konservativere union sondern sie ist die
eigentliche neue ware npd und mit
solchen leuten macht man nicht einmal
bekämpft sie und zwar engagiert und
streitbar liebe freunde
ob söder vielleicht auch noch in den
kampf um die kanzlerkandidatur der union
einsteigt der franke lässt es sich heute
zumindest nicht anmerken
die letzte zitterpartie für seine
gastgeberin der antrag auf uhr weil eben
jener kandidatur
doch als es zur abstimmung kommt sind 80
prozent der anwesenden delegierten
dagegen andere anträge wie der das
chinesische staatsunternehmen huawei vom
ausbau des 5g netzes in deutschland
auszuschließen wurden schon im vorfeld
entschärft die personaldebatte erstmal
ad acta gelegt auch sonst viel einigkeit
demonstriert die mehrheit im saal
scheint zufrieden mit dem leipziger
parteitag
wir haben mal gezeigte einigkeit geht
auch also insofern ich bin ganz angetan
wir haben das was in der öffentlichkeit
stattfindet nicht gemacht nämlich
personaldebatten geführt und ich glaube
wir haben in vielen fragen schwung
geholt für die kommenden monate
wir brauchen mehr positive energie wir
brauchen mehr geschlossenheit und das
ist das was die cdu mitglieder wollen
aber das ist auch das was die leute im
land wollen in einem jahr in stuttgart
soll dann entschieden werden wer die
union in den nächsten
bundestagswahlkampf führt es gehört zu
den weniger angenehmen aufgaben im
journalismus derzeit über rechtsextreme
und neonazis zu recherchieren
da bekommt man es leicht mit menschen zu
tun die sich für berechtigt halten
widerstand zu leisten gegen eine freie
presse mit der sie nicht einverstanden
sind einzelne journalisten zur
zielscheibe von demonstrationen zu
machen kann den betreffenden angst
einflüssen so heute in hannover bei
einer demonstration gegen namentlich
genannte journalisten die in diesem
milieu recherchiert und gefilmt haben
und damit an die öffentlichkeit ging zur
pressefreiheit muss auch das recht
gehören als reporter ohne angst arbeiten
zu dürfen
dieses recht wurde heute in hannover in
frage gestellt von vielleicht zehn
dutzend rechten demonstranten und
verteidigt von tausenden anderen
elisabeth schmidt berichtet bürger die
hannovers innenstadt nicht den
rechtsextremen überlassen wollen und
gegen die demonstrieren die seit monaten
journalisten einschüchtern bedrohen
bis vor ihre haustür verfolgen wir sind
mehr schreiben sie in bunten farben 7000
menschen ziehen für die pressefreiheit
auf die straße wenn es soweit kommt dass
sie angst haben müssen dass im grunde
genommen ein ganzer berufsstand
eingeschüchtert wird dann haben wir ein
richtiges problem das möchte ich nicht
mit zu lassen müssen
einige straßen weiter rund 120
npd-anhänger plakate eines ehemaligen ss
mannes ein held der rechtsextremen und
ihr feind der öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk am pranger journalisten die
kritisch über die rechte szene berichten
unter ihnen julian feldmann reporter des
norddeutschen rundfunks
da ist man schon ein stück weit
erschrocken wenn man das zum ersten mal
ist und dann auch den flyer der npd
sieht wo ein bild von einem raucher ist
das durchgestrichen ist durchgestrichen
ist ein neuer schritt nächstes level
sozusagen an bedrohung feldmann hatte
vor einem jahr kein münter interviewt
der ehemalige ss-mann relativierte dabei
den holocaust und verhöhnte die opfer
eines massakers der nationalsozialisten
die npd nennt den bericht linke
propaganda und ruft bei ihrer
demonstration in hannover zu
gerechtigkeit für carl auf das hat schon
eine neue qualität und für viele ist das
gleichzeitig auch der aufruf dazu oder
er wird so verstanden sich daran auch
aus zu lassen also möglicherweise sogar
gewalttätig auszulassen
das ist eine strategie der
einschüchterung doch neben angriffen auf
die fresse wie auch hier in hannover
verfolgt die npd noch eine ganz andere
strategie
gemessen an ihren politischen einfluss
sind die rechtsextremen fast in der
bedeutungslosigkeit verschwunden
doch rund 80 demonstrationen allein in
diesem jahr zeigen die rand partei sucht
aufmerksamkeit wie afg sammelt ja nur
eine menge stimmen ein die npd sehr
marginalisiert ist das auch ihr versucht
nach vorne zu spielen weil sie ihre
felle wegschwimmen sehen über der
parteienlandschaft also ich muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen also ich habe eine
ganz andere strategie ich kann gewisse
sachen die die afg sagt gar nicht sagen
ich hätte dafür im gefängnis
so einfach ist das und sie können das
dann sollen sie das tun
ich werde mich nicht auf der straße
weiter radikalisieren nur um die afg an
der außenseite zu überholen die npd
rechts von der afg um beachtung kämpfen
verschafft sich mit hetze gegen
journalisten öffentlichkeit ihre
genehmigte demonstration schützt der
start mit viel aufwand doch am ende
eines langen tages sind es diese bilder
die bleiben werden
sie alle waren mehr hannover ist für die
pressefreiheit auf die straße gegangen
nachrichten von heinz außenminister maas
hat bei seinem türkischen amtskollegen
kabul gegen die festnahme eines anwalts
der deutschen botschaft protestiert
der anwalt hatte im deutschen auftrag
die angaben von asylbewerbern überprüft
soll bei seiner festnahme sensible daten
türkischer staatsbürger bei sich gehabt
haben
maas sprach mit java schule am rande des
g20-treffens in japan über den fall
ich habe mir noch einmal gesagt dass wir
eigentlich kein verständnis dafür haben
und es ist noch einmal gesagt worden
dass der fall nun von der türkischen
justiz geprüft wird letztlich ist das
ein fall der bedauerlicherweise wie viel
zu viele andere fälle in der türkei für
uns nicht nachvollziehbar ist deshalb
werden wir mit den verantwortlichen in
der türkei dazu auch im gespräch bleibt
nachdem die bundesregierung in zwei
gerichtsentscheidungen aufgefordert
wurde
nicht nur kinder mit deutscher
staatsangehörigkeit auslagern in syrien
zurück zu holen sondern auch deren
mütter gibt es heute offenbar eine erste
solche rückholung es soll sich um eine
30 jährige aus hessen handeln die in das
kriegsgebiet gereist und dort einen es
kämpfer geheiratet haben soll
ihre ankunft war für den abend in
frankfurt am main erwartet worden
der illegal nach deutschland eingereist
der libanesische klein chef ibrahim miri
ist abgeschoben worden die bundespolizei
übergab den mehrfach vorbestraften an
die behörden in beirut meriva bereits im
juli abgeschoben worden ende oktober
tauchte er dann wieder in bremen auf und
beantragte asyl
das wurde abgelehnt innenminister
seehofer dankte allen beteiligten
stellen für die schnelle abschiebung in
paris und anderen französischen städten
gab es heute demonstrationen gegen
gewalt an frauen
allein in paris gingen mehrere
zehntausend menschen auf die straße
gefordert wurde ein besserer schutz für
frauen in frankreich sind nach angaben
von aktivisten in diesem jahr bereits
mindestens 137 frauen von ihrem partner
oder ex-partner getötet worden über das
thema gibt es seit einigen monaten in
frankreich eine verstärkte debatte am
montag will die regierung die ergebnisse
eines runden tisches dazu vorstellen
hongkong die stadt mit dem magischen
nahmen mit ihren sieben millionen
einwohnern für chinesische verhältnisse
nicht besonders groß ist ein brennpunkt
geworden für die konfrontation zwischen
einer freiheit nicht demokratischen
ordnung und dem totalen machtanspruch
einer staatspartei die führung in peking
rechnet sich aus dass sie sich keinen
kompromiss leisten kann
ihre propaganda erzählt die
ordnungsmacht müsste friedliche bürger
von hongkong vor hemmungslosen vandalen
schützen und zwar mit allen mit unser
korrespondent ulf röller berichtet was
ihm dort begegnet und quer
casey war zum beispiel ein hongkong
mensch von unfassbarem gleichmut schau
der china an sagte er die sind bereit
hongkong zu opfern
das würde ihnen nichts ausmachen das
sind dieselben leute die ein bataillon
soldaten auf den tiananmen platz
schicken
casey wong ist einer der berühmtesten
künstler seiner stadt erstellt in der
ganzen welt aus dem protest von
hongkongs jugend gegen das mächtige
china widmet er seine ganze
schaffenskraft für meinen krieg benutze
ich die kunst ich habe bisher keinen
einzigen stein geworfen obwohl ich
darüber nachgedacht habe
aber ich will nicht diesen weg
einschlagen
ich will das machen was ich am besten
kann kunst und damit kämpfe ich meinen
krieg der tägliche kreislauf der gewalt
bekommt in seiner kunst etwas erhabenes
und träumerisches sowie vox hoffnung auf
eine welt die hongkongs jugend nicht
vergisst alle mächtigen dieser welt
sollten zusammenkommen eine rote linie
ziehen und china sagen wenn du zur
internationale gemeinschaft dazu gehören
willst dann musst du dich benehmen
hongkong steht wohl am scheideweg nach
den monaten der gewalt die stadt legt
sich ihre wunden
widerstand gibt es in vielen formen
restaurants unterstützen die
demonstranten und bekommen dafür viel
besuch
banker und makler protestieren auf den
straßen gegen die peking treue
hongkonger regierung und werden sofort
von der polizei in voller schutzkleidung
gestellt jeder wird verdächtigt
gewalttätig zu sein
die meisten demonstranten sind studenten
aber wir wollen zeigen dass auch wir
erwachsenen und die arbeitenden sie
unterstützen
der traurigste ort der stadt ist die
polytechnische universität dort haben
sich immer noch studentin verschanzt ihm
drohen festnahmen und haftstrafen von
zehn jahren wegen aufruhrs sie nennen
sich von kleiner frontkämpfer beide sind
erst 17 und bauten barrikaden tägliche
gewalt gehört mittlerweile zu ihrem
leben sie sagen sätze für die sie zu
jung sind
in zukunft werde ich entweder in einer
freien stadt leben wo ich frei reden
kann oder ich lande im gefängnis oder
ich werde tot sein
casey war kennt viele der radikalen
jugendlichen sie sind seine studenten er
fürchtet ihre entschlossenheit bewundert
ihren willen
wir machen das obwohl es schwierig ist
denn wenn du deine ziele füllst ist das
großartig
und dann spielt er glory to hongkong die
hymne der proteste bei uns ist es gleich
23 uhr in hongkong dämmert schon der
sonntagmorgen es wird ein wahltag
kommunalwahlen mit beschränkter freiheit
und trotzdem könnten sie ein signal
senden
morgen abend berichten wir darüber jetzt
haben wir erst mal den service zu bieten
der zum samstag journal gehört
lottozahlen sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
5 11 24 26 28 36 superzahl 5 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
die menschen im nordwesten italiens
kämpfen gegen schwere überschwemmungen
heftige regenfälle verursachen in genua
erdrutsche mehrere straßen waren
blockiert
auch im südosten frankreichs gibt es
ähnliche bilder an der côte d'azur
mussten hunderte menschen vorsorglich
ihre häuser verlassen
ein mann wird vermisst hier wird das
wetter in den nächsten tagen so morgen
im norden wechselnd oder stark bewölkt
sonst nach teils zäher nebelauflösung
häufig sonne höchstwerte 6 bis 14 grad
am montag und dienstag oft bewölkt oder
neblig trüb aber nur vereinzelt regen am
mittwoch häufiger regen bei meist milden
temperaturen einen schönen sonntag in
und bis 9
ja danke sagen
[Musik]